alors partagez-le avec nous qu'est-ce que vous écrivez
mes mémoires je le savais la seule vraie
question qu'on devrait se poser durant
notre existence c'est combien coûte la
vie d'un homme pour moi je suis plus de 20 millions de dollars
et je remets jusqu'au dernier dollar allons-
y  mon ancienne vie est de retour
tout le monde sait ce que cet endroit
est fermé shillong survivre un instant
avons-nous toujours les mêmes noms ouais nous sommes
la famille Blake bienvenue vous savez où
je pourrais le trouver vous savez que c'est bien que
vous et votre famille n'ayez que du temps ici  pour
m'assurer que cela n'arrive pas j'essaie de ne pas faire
un bon travail impossible
il y a une chose que je n'aime pas c'est
être interrompu le mieux c'est de se cacher en
normandie le trouver qu'est-ce
qu'Al Capone a toujours dit
lui demander poli avec une arme à nouveau
est  mieux que de simplement demander poliment
ce que vous apprenez à travailler, laissez-moi vous montrer